HTML 5 edit types for phone numbers, email addresses,
URLs, numbers and dates, among others. For each one of
these fields, I can go into the depth fields and
change it. For example, email, right now, gives me the
standard keyboard. But, if I go in and change
its type to email, you may notice one subtle difference.
And I now get an @ symbol on my keyboard
by default. Some of the biggest changes were for dates,
where I now get an actual calendar and colors, where not only do I
get a nice color selection box, but I can actually edit the color. And finally,
there's a simple number input type. You'll
notice this is somewhat like the number input
for telephone numbers, except there's no alpha
numeric's and there's no hash and star sign.